in high school he took an AP stats class
and he complained that none of the
methods made sense since they're all
based on the arbitrary assumption that
every every relationship was a straight
line we all know about the best linear
estimator is best unbiased linear
estimator
so his teacher told him statistics was
not the subject for him
and over a decade later he has a degree
in statistics and his job is literally
to convince people stop using methods
that draw straight lines
please welcome George
hey everybody it's great to be here
today I'm going to be talking about
Bayesian boosting or how I learned to
stop worrying and love uncertainty
so I want to begin by offering everybody
a choice we have some outcome of
interest you can imagine any outcome
you'd like just with the constraint that
we want it to be higher we want to
maximize this outcome and fortunately
for us we have a statistical model
that's going to help us make a choice
and for option A our model is going to
tell us that we're expecting a value of
nine
for option b our model is going to tell
us that we're expecting a value of nine
and given this information we really
have no reason to prefer one choice over
the other
now the only thing is I've left out some
information from our model
and that is
option A according to our model has a 95
chance of being between
negative 3 and 11. option b is predicted
to be between 8 and 10.
now this may make us think a little bit
differently
about which one we prefer
and so I'm going to use some
hypothetical data
um we can imagine any continuous outcome
if this was a you could imagine it being
a study of subjective well-being and Z
is a binary variable it could be whether
or not you're participating in a
meditation program or an exercise
regimen an X could be the number of
hours you're working every week
why could be some variable like income
taxes current earnings y would be future
earnings Z is whether or not you're
enrolled in some type of jobs training
program or if you're not
now
if you wanted to model this data we
could start with just fitting a linear
regression but it looks pretty
non-linear so that's probably not a
great start there's also not a ton of
observations so methods like deep
learning probably wouldn't fare
particularly well
and so where does this leave us well a
natural approach would be using some
type of tree based method to model this
and we're going to build up some
intuition ultimately getting to Bayesian
boosting which is a Bayesian version of
boosted regression trees but before we
get there we're going to talk about tree
methods in general
and so the idea of a regression tree
which is at the center of all of these
types of tree base methods is if we
could only make one cut in our data
what's that cut going to be
and then
after making that cut we kind of go in
those two groups
what's the next best cut and best is
defined as where are we dividing up our
data to get the best predictions
so this is a regression tree fit to our
data and if you kind of follow down we
have 199 people on our sample so if you
have a z value of zero it turns out Z is
kind of the best cut first
you're over here and then within Z
values of zero if you have an x value of
less than 12
you fall down to here
and the bottom of the tree it's called
The Leaf is just the prediction so for
everybody in this kind of cluster of
data we'd predict a score of 78. now if
you had a z value of 1
we would be over here and then if you
let's say a particular individual or a
group of individuals with X values above
44 would uh fall over here and then
splitting on X again we end up in a leaf
down here so for those folks with Z of
One X over 44 and then y over 52 they
would have a prediction of 118. and so
this is a way of kind of splitting up
our data without making any pesky linear
assumptions
so is our job done why not just use a
regression tree the problem is where do
we stop we can just keep splitting and
splitting and splitting and splitting
until we just have a prediction for each
person in our data set and it's a
perfect prediction now
that may seem very well and good but
most of the time we're not just
interested about our sample but making
generalizations to broader populations
and if we use this model on unseen data
those predictions would be grossly
overfit
so usually you rely on some type of
cross validation to kind of trim the
tree and keep it a little bit smaller
there's a few different ways to do it
sometimes you encode hard rules like say
when we get to a little any of these
splits if there's less than 20 people in
there we're just going to stop the tree
can't get any deeper some people use
explicit forms of cross-validation on
out of sample tests here I use some
version of cross validation
and if we look at how this fares on our
on our test set we have an rsme around
two we can see we're kind of
non-linearly modeling the data and it's
just making these kind of crude means
within splits
if you look at how we perform on some
unseen data
our error goes up a little bit but it's
not grossly overfit our predictions are
still pretty well
but there may be a way that we can
squeeze out some more predictive power
by instead of relying on one large
regression tree what if we harness the
power of many small regression trees
and this is the intuition of what's
called gradient boosted regression trees
instead of using one tree to fit all of
our to fit our data make predictions
we're going to force trees to be really
really small and then we're actually
going to use some parameters usually
they're called uh called learning rate
or shrinkage to make those predictions
even smaller these learning rates are
always less than one it's a tunable
parameter you tune it by cross
validation and if you multiply a number
by something less than one it's going to
get smaller so we have a little
prediction from a little tree and we're
going to squeeze it even smaller
and we're going to do this a lot of
times hundreds of trees 100 trees 150
trees and we're going to sum up
all of the values from the street now
some people here may be familiar with
random Forest we're not going to talk
about that today just know that random
Forest is doing something very different
it's averaging over trees this is a
literal sum and so each tree is
contributing a tiny bit in the case of
gradient boosted trees all of the
contributions is kind of dependent on
the prior tree
and we tune a few parameters like how
many trees uh how deep can the trees be
you have to set a max depth should we
let it go down to three should be cap it
two should we let go down to six that's
a pretty deep tree and all of these
things have implications for whether or
not we're overfitting our data
now this may still be a little bit
confusing so I want to walk through the
process of what actually happens with
gradient boosted trees so without any
other information
the best prediction we have is just the
overall average so we start with this
this is the overall average
we're going to see how each of our
points compared to the average and we're
going to save that it's called the
residual and then we're going to fit a
tiny regression Tree on that residual
tiny defined by the values of the hyper
parameters we used how deep can it be
and the shrinkage parameter and so we're
going to fit this we're going to
multiply the fits by the shrinkage
parameter and add it so this is our
first tree and as you can see it's just
a little a little prediction it's not
going to fare well on our overall data
set
we're going to compare how the residuals
are to this tree multiply it by the
shrinkage parameter
and then sum up tree one and two and
that gets us here
we're going to see how the residuals
compared to this fit fit another Tree on
those residuals multiply by the Learning
rate AKA shrinkage parameter
and we get this and we're just going to
keep repeating and slowly and slowly our
model is going to get more and more and
more flexible jumping ahead to the 50th
tree
I'm sorry to the tenth tree to get
something like this
and then if we jump ahead to the 50th
tree we see it's continuing to grow and
grow and grow just very very slowly and
the slow growth is what prevents us from
overfitting
and if we see how this fares on our
training set we picked up much better
predictions our model is much more
flexible now it's really hugging the
points tightly
but this is the training data set and
the question is is this too good to be
true
if we saw some unseen data
maybe things are a little bit different
so we have a little bit more air but our
regularization's still performing pretty
well and this is because I cross
validated I cross-validated this this uh
GBM model this gradient boosted model
um specifically running many many many
models on subsets of the training set to
kind of optimize these parameters and it
takes a lot of time there's many ways to
do it and there's a lot of unknowns how
long do we cross validate what options
do we use these are all things that you
are kind of left up to the user it's
very time intensive very computationally
intensive
but our prediction
is still much better than our single
regression tree so we're making progress
so even though gradient boosted trees
has given us better predictions it's not
answering that uncertainty part of the
problem
if I gave you a prediction somewhere in
this tree I don't know how credible that
prediction is how much should I believe
it how how much is our model really
believe that prediction
and to answer these questions about our
model's uncertainty
we need to move into a Bayesian
framework
there are other ways to talk about
uncertainty but a natural way is a
Bayesian inferential framework in which
we're going to keep the non-parametric
machine learning approach and combine
the inference abilities
Bayesian inference this is the formal
model for the Bayesian version of
regression trees uh it's called Bayesian
out of regression trees we don't need to
get two into the math the only details
to know is this just means it's a sum of
many many small trees there's some error
term learned from the data we're gonna
assume it's independent
and just like with gradient boosted
trees we're going to sum all of them up
now the difference here G on all of
those trees we're no longer setting
things like a learning rate we've thrown
that away in in the Bayesian framework
now we're going to rely on Bayesian
priors to shrink all these trees so in
this equation G is going to be the new
equivalent of that point one that
learning rate that shrinkage thing but
we're not explicitly setting it we're
not going to cross validate it
it's just going to be a we're going to
talk about these beliefs in a little bit
m is just many tree is the many trees
sorry m is the means T is the trees So
within each tree we have means for
people just like the first regression
tree which have a lot a lot of really
small ones
and we're going to draw from a posterior
distribution with a Gib sampler if you
don't know what that is
it's not important
uh
this is still a little confusing how
this works so so we're not cross-valid
anymore
um and in the beige and framework we're
not even really fitting trees the same
way anymore
what's going to happen is trees are
going to be proposed we have a certain
amount of rules that trees could be
maybe we want to grow a tree deeper
maybe we want to make a tree smaller
maybe you want to kind of change things
around in the tree what if we just kind
of experimented by flipping those split
rules these are all different types of
proposals we could make
and we're going to propose a given Tree
in which type of rule we use it's just
going to be kind of randomly picked and
whether or not we accept that proposal
or reject it is going to be a decision
made that favors improving the fit it's
not a hard rule we're not going to pick
anything that automatically improves it
there's still a little bit of Randomness
in there but we're going to favor stuff
that slowly improves the fit now I
talked about that g parameter or kind of
throwing away the idea of a learning
rate
so how do we do that well we have some
beliefs about how trees should look
and we're going to use probability
distributions
to add those beliefs into our
statistical model
so I'd like to talk about what are our
actual beliefs about our trees well we
believe we should be skeptical about
predictions that are really far from the
average if our model was giving us a
total ton of extreme things really
really outliers
it's kind of a sign of overfitting so we
should be a little bit worried about
that if we see a lot of extreme
predictions maybe we want to kind of
pull them into the center a little bit
we also know that trees should be small
we know this from GBM we know some
regression trees if you let them grow
too deep we really start ramping up the
risk of overfitting
and we also believe that our model
should be able to outperform linear
regression
this is usually used in cases where we
believe the data is not linear in this
example in two-dimensional space if you
can explicitly see that it's not in
higher dimensional space it's very rare
the data is actually linear so in some
ways this is even the best situation and
we already know that assumption is
failing so we believe
our non-parametric models should do a
little bit better than that
and so we incorporate those beliefs into
explicit priors we have a prior on the
means which is those Leafs of the
regression tree it's our predictions we
have a prior on the trees we have a
prior on the error term
which is just our residual
and these priors are going to give a
strong predictive performance without
the need to rely on Cross validation
and all of the results I'm going to show
you with Bart have been done with no
cross validation at all I just use the
default put in the data and fit and this
is what it spat out
now we can talk a little bit more about
the priors I'm not going to get into it
too much
you can read more about this outside if
you're really interested in it or you
can talk to me after but
the gist of it is
we're going to scale all the data to the
mean zero that means the average and we
can see extreme predictions and if
they're extreme we're just going to pull
it back in we think that about 95 of our
data should be a couple standard
deviations away from the mean that's the
idea that prior on mu
prior on T we're going to give
probabilities that trees can be
certain depths so we know we probably
need more than a depth one so we'll give
that about five percent most of the time
we want to be in the depth of two depth
of three so we've got a 55 chance of
proposing a tree that is depth two and a
28 of depth three and then we've got
depth four and five
now this is not a hard cap on five if
the data demands it during this kind of
proposal process remember we're going to
slowly favor fits that
improve the overall fit we're going to
favor trees that improve the fit
so it's possible to have a depth of 17
in some of the initial work on this they
saw trees with a depth of 17 they were
counteracted by many many trees of a
depth one so it can happen if the data
demands it
and all this is just due to this kind of
metropolis Hastings proposal rejection
system
we have some prior and sigma I'm not
going to get into it too much we
calibrate it explicitly with a linear
regression so we fit it with a linear
regression and we usually pick kind of a
default distribution saying it's
distributed chi-squared and we think our
model is going to fall within this range
compared to linear regression
um
and it's just kind of giving us a
starting point to inform how much error
to add to our predictions
so I've been talking about this
hypothetical case 200 people
two variables
what I say may be interesting but may
feel a little bit ungeneralizable so
this is some data from the initial paper
about bart Bayesian added regression
trees I.E bayesians boosting
and it shows that with default bar
without any cross validation at all it's
performing better than other top tier
machine learning algorithms like
boosting neural networks and random
forests and this is just straight out of
the box with no cross validation whereas
all of the other models have been
cross-validated and these results are
from 42 data sets with 800 trained test
splits so this is this is a pretty this
is a more generalizable type of sample
and then when we do cross-validate Bart
which you can do some of these priors
you do have to set certain
distributional
um assumptions about you can tune the
values of these distributions a little
bit and further improve performance but
even if you don't
your predictions are still going to be
really good so how does all this
translate to our data I'm going to speed
up a little bit um
this is just some examples we're going
to randomly fit the trees this is an
example of tree that got accepted
another tree
gets proposed and accepted this is an
example of tree slowly growing
this is an example of when we flip trees
a lot of random proposals are happening
we're just proposing new type of tree
new type of tree and it's either going
to get accepted or rejected there's some
cases where
um where trees don't change see this is
staying the same because our proposal is
rejected so we're going to stay the same
and we're just going to slowly build a
force of trees just on this
probabilistic except reject kind of
trading back and forth
sometimes our trees get really small all
of these things are possible within the
framework I've outlined and now applied
to our own data
our train sets really amazing now we may
be looking at this and be like there's
no way this isn't overfit
and if you look at the test set
it's not particularly overfit in fact
our test set error is lower than the
training set for gradient boosted trees
in this example and there's without any
cross validation at all
now that last spot was even
oversimplification these lines aren't
the real predictions each prediction is
a distribution
and so if we wanted to zoom in on an
individual
we have a whole distribution
quantifying how credible we think this
prediction is
because sure our model has
thinks that a value of 105 is more
likely than 102 but 102 is still likely
it's still possible
and we can quantify How likely our model
thinks this is
and this is getting back to what I
opened with of knowing information about
the uncertainty in our model can be a
really important asset when we're trying
to make decisions
now
sometimes we end up making predictions
in areas that we haven't seen before so
you can imagine we fit a model based on
our training set and then this red Point
shows up and we need one we want to make
a prediction about him
now the issue is
they're kind of in this group down here
this is a value of Z zero but we don't
know what happens to Z zero folks over
here so all of our models are blind and
machine learning can't really fix this
but it will give a prediction here's our
prediction from gradient boosted trees
here's our prediction from a regression
tree and it's going to give it to it to
you and it's going to be very confident
that prediction in fact it's just going
to give you the number and you have to
believe it
but what if we could actually quantify
that we're really uncertain over here
and so as we extrapolate into areas of
the space that we haven't seen before
Bart is going to be honest that it
really is not comfortable with the
prediction so here we're not even
covering the real observation
but the distribution grows the point
where if you looked at the distribution
you would know we're extrapolating into
areas we probably shouldn't be
and in multi-dimensional space you
wouldn't be able to see
that there's no data here
but the uncertainty would still exist so
using bard-based methods allows us to
recognize when we're kind of
extrapolating into areas that we
shouldn't even if we can't directly see
it
now
most of my work we're expanding this
into causal inference
you could really think about causal
inference as a prediction problem
we're not just interested in predicting
individuals or intern predicting what
would have happened if we flipped
somebody's value of Z1 to zero in other
words what's the causal effect of Zeon y
and the these tools can be really useful
in the same way as we get a prediction
for an individual we can also get
predictions and coherent credible
intervals that can be interpreted as
probabilities
about entire groupings and parameters we
can make statements about the
relationship between z and y given a
certain set of causal assumptions is
satisfied
if you're doing causal imprints you
should read up on what those assumptions
are here we're making a heavy heavy
assumption that we've measured all
confounders
and we can automatically detect any
heterogeneity or treatment effect
thanks so much if you're interested in
learning these methods using these
methods on your own implemented an r in
the debarts package bar cost will cause
causal inference stand for Bart for
multi-level models and think causal if
you want to use a point-and-click system
and don't have to don't want to worry
about any of the programming of this
um